what's going on guys this is rob and we
are back with more batman stuff right
batman the imposter we will actually
have this finished uh tomorrow so
friday this should be done uh so here's
the thing so what we do is we basically
pick up with kind of like to a degree
the origin of batman i mean the origin
batman is like universal right thomas
and martha wayne are shot in front of
bruce and then you know how it unfolds
from there is relative to the story but
the thing about this is that we actually
end up having leslie tomkins who was the
initial therapist for bruce wayne kind
of running over the case notes from when
she had originally seen him and one of
the things we learned is that in the
aftermath of bruce wayne's parents dying
uh that in boarding school he found
himself just getting into a series of
fights right conflicts different things
like that now when it comes to kids
usually operating in that capacity it's
usually like an external form of
basically expressing how they're feeling
on the inside so if they're angry then
they'll express that through anger right
so they'll basically just get into
fights conflicts things along those
lines what's interesting here is when
she asks him why did you get into a
fight with them the response is because
they think they're better than everybody
right like all these people these kids
at this prep school they think they're
better than everybody else and so as she
sees it from where she's sitting right
off the bat he's got social withdrawal
oppositional defiance disorder ptsd a
lack of empathy and acute anxiety along
with ocd so the kid's got a host of
things that he's basically struggling
with what's interesting about this is
like the oppositional defiant disorder
because it's one of those things where
he's kind of like those people think
they're better than other people but the
response of leslie is that may very well
be true bruce but we have to keep you in
the status quo right our goal here is to
basically make you like everybody else
and so it's one of those things where if
this is left unchecked he could end up
developing anti-social personality
disorder and that would make him
different than people which of course on
a societal level we know isn't really
something that we tolerate too much so
in order to ensure that he remains like
everybody else uh she basically ends up
saying like this is something that needs
to be treated now the problem with this
is that alfred is basically at its wits
end right alfred's kind of looking at
this from the perspective of like i
don't know how to do this anymore i
can't handle this anymore right the kid
starts tearing stuff up in the house
just losing his mind and what's really
interesting about this is bruce wayne in
this story reacts though reacts to his
parents death the way you would
genuinely expect him to right the way
you would expect really any kid to react
in that capacity right losing your
parents in the blink of an eye like
right in front of you witnessing such a
heinous and violent action that would
drive anybody crazy right it would get
you know put any kid in the point where
they basically just start expressing
himself through rage and anger the the
the staff are absolutely terrified of
him and it gets to the point where
alfred's just like is there any way we
can just medicate this kid and call it a
day right that's one of the things about
this like i grew up in the 1990s well
technically i was born in 84 but i'm
basically a 90s kid those of you guys
who aren't familiar with that the 90s
were the decade of medication right like
every problem with a kid could be solved
with medication largely because parents
just didn't know what they were doing so
they turned to the easiest solution
that's kind of us as people we want the
greatest reward for the least amount of
work possible and so that was just kind
of the thing that everybody did in the
90s was just medicaid everybody but in
the end what is happening is that
because leslie tompkins is like i'm not
gonna just medicate this kid because
you're a lazy butler because you this is
just a little more than you can handle
the the result is that bruce wayne is
basically shipped off to a military
school in russia and then in turn alfred
basically quits right he just like
leaves on the spot and so in a lot of
ways leslie tompkins carries this around
as a personal failure she sees it as
something that she had basically screwed
up where she wasn't able to bring bruce
back from this edge that he was on and
ultimately it led him down the path that
he's currently on now the funny thing
about this and what's really interesting
is that if the anti-social personality
disorder of bruce wayne has led him to
become batman which in turn has made a
more marked change like a has basically
improved gotham city in a way that
anybody without anti-social personality
was able to do does that mean it's a bad
thing and that's what's interesting
right like is something a bad thing if
the net benefit of it is a good thing
right that's kind of what's interesting
there right do the ends justify the
means in other words in a lot of ways
yes right i mean you know that's kind of
how we are as people we don't care what
happens to the cow so long as the steak
tastes good when we get it i mean we'll
say we care but like our actions show
that we basically don't and so it's just
one of those things where it's just kind
of really interesting in regards to like
this philosophical perspective but again
the you know when she ends up talking to
him of course he's all kind of scarred
up as bruce wayne normally is right all
cut up and all that kind of stuff one of
the things he establishes is that
because wesker capital is in a lot of
ways the financial benefactor of gotham
city one of the things he realized here
is that they have eyes and ears
everywhere so being able to access their
surveillance system is paramount the
problem with this is that once he gets
in there of course he's got to overcome
the guards because remember this version
of batman doesn't have the same kind of
stealth and guile that we're normally
used to seeing in dc comics instead it's
a more realistic portrayal of his
character dude walks in through the
front door and just starts beating the
hell out of everybody
[Laughter]
right just just just straight up beating
everybody up the problem with this is
that while he is able to gain access to
their surveillance system ultimately he
doesn't really put one of the guys down
for the count and he ends up basically
hitting the button that essentially
alerts like the giant bodyguard guy who
shows up in a fight ensues batman's
overpowered and then that's effectively
it batman ends up getting you know
getting the absolute tar beaten out of
it now what's really also interesting
here is in the last video we talked
about the name of wesker and we talked
about how wesker is one of those guys
who basically ends up becoming the
ventriloquist in the main dc line of
comics what's really cool here is that
arnold wesker is actually the son the
one that's kind of been talking to
himself and sort of rambling to himself
different things like that and what it
basically does is it kind of points in
the direction that he will eventually
become the ventriloquist we're not
really given any absolute certainty here
but i mean he literally holds a
ventriloquist doll now the way that
works at least as i understand it from
my knowledge of the ventriloquist and
the stories that i've read is that
arnold wesker is basically a guy with
multiple personality disorder and as a
result of that one of those
personalities manifests in the form of
the ventriloquist doll it's kind of his
uh his his baseline desires for like
violence and destruction and so on right
everything he wishes he was is
manifested in how the ventriloquist doll
talks so maybe not necessarily multiple
personality disorder in like the
traditional sense but you guys
understand what i'm saying now the funny
thing is that where bruce wayne
encounters him he could have overcome
him right like literally wesker asked
bruce wayne like will you kill my father
and the response of bruce just doesn't
come he never really says anything he
just ultimately leaves and when leslie
asks him about that the response here is
i mean to a degree he kind of felt bad
for him he doesn't really say as much
but it's just one of those things where
it's kind of like you know i mean he
just he could have just pummeled him
right he could have just beat him up or
he could have just said no or something
like that instead he simply just leaves
and so what you get here is a really
interesting situation where you jump
back to the moment when uh when blair
wong shows up on the doorstep of bruce
wayne at wayne manor and starts asking
him about like the motorcycles and all
that kind of stuff right everything's
been going on in the last video where
like the there were like 60 some odd
motorcycles that had been impounded and
one of the things that she had picked up
on is that while pretty much all of the
identification numbers the vins were
essentially gone there was no indication
of who they actually belonged to they
did find a serial number tied to one of
the tires that basically showed that the
motorcycle was purchased by wayne
industries and there's no reason to
believe all the others weren't as well
so for no other reason than to track
down a lead and while she doesn't really
suspect bruce wayne per se a kind of uh
interesting bit of a romance forms
between the two of them right not in the
sense that like i mean well i guess you
know not immediate instead it's just
kind of one of those general things
where he's kind of like look if i if i
think of anything or if i come up with
anything i'll give you a call right i'll
i'll talk to you now one of the things
to know is that this is bruce wayne
being manipulative right he knows that
wong has information that he needs but
he knows that wong won't readily give it
to him because bruce wayne's not working
with her on the case and if you were a
suspect she wouldn't give him
information that would make it easier
for him to dodge the police and so
there's just no real way for him to get
that info and so what he basically
calculates here is the idea that the
best way to get that info is to
basically manipulate her right to use
her for his own ends to kind of pump her
for information now the funny thing is
she kind of does that to a degree but
the two of them basically end up meeting
up for lunch and once he has this
conversation with her and saying hey
look so uh so here's the thing right
there were i was asking my people to
look for any kind of discrepancies in
our import logs or anything like that
and he says 18 months ago we had a
missing shipment container that was
never accounted for and it apparently
had 25 motorcycles in it now when she
asked the question why didn't you
contact the cops he's like i mean it's
one missing container out of 2200 we're
not really that concerned about it
especially if all it had in it were
motorcycles right it's not really the a
super important thing to us if it had
like microchips that could launch
nuclear missiles across the world sure
we would probably tell someone right but
until then we didn't necessarily have a
reason to now one of the funny things is
where she kind of where she asked to ask
him the question you know hey like why
are you even coming to me and telling me
all this in the first place he's like
well i looked you up right i got curious
and i just kind of did some poking
around on you i know people who know
people they were able to give me a
little bit of background information on
you and i realized how much we had in
common and where she hits on this idea
that like both of us saw our parents
killed in front of each other because
that's blair wong's story she witnessed
the death of her parents in in front of
her that bruce is kind of like no i was
talking about the fact that we both
dropped out of yale that you spent time
in brazil that i spent a few years there
as well that kind of a thing and just
kind of manipulating her here right i
mean the reality is she hit the nail on
the head right i mean for him that's the
thing that can be used to unify them to
a degree but he can allude to it by
simply saying well you know we have a
lot in common and that where bruce
wayne's story is just well-known
information even within the people of
gotham and really even just around the
world uh blair wong's story is very
similar to that so by allowing her to
draw those lines and then saying no
that's not what i was talking about at
all and then making her feel a sense of
guilt now she feels a sense of owing him
and that's when he's like no no i mean
it's cool right you could let me buy you
breakfast that's where the charm kicks
up that's the nature of antisocial
personality disorder the people with
that mental illness if they use it in
the most extreme degree are incredibly
charming but ridiculously manipulative
right like they will use you for their
own ends and then get rid of you as soon
as they're done right so that's that's
the thing right it's not one of those
things where it's like well i mean okay
i mean that's fine but you can pay me
back by like giving me all your case
notes it's weaseling in right it's
saying like you can let me buy you
breakfast right and the more they spend
time together and the more they talk the
more that a kind of attraction begins to
grow between the two of them now one
thing to understand is that love has a
mind of its own right there's no
controlling it there's no there's no
categorizing quantifying and keeping
love isolated to this one part of your
life so i won't go as far as to say that
like bruce wayne realized his heart was
three sizes too small and it got bigger
right he's not the grinch but i will say
that the the affection he feels for wong
moves away from like she's an asset that
i can use to attain information and
actually starts to grow into i think i'm
falling in love with her so much so the
two of them actually spend the night
together and so one of the things that
goes on which is really kind of crazy
here is basically of course she kind of
asked him like where did you get this
scar from where'd you get that scar from
and where he's where the reality is like
he was cut right or he was like hit with
a 2x4 or something like that he can't
tell her well when i was running around
in the middle of the night last night
and i was beating up criminals one of
them slashed me right it's just one of
those uh car accident right it was a
skiing accident i mean blair wong's no
idiot but it's also one of those things
where like when we're in that position
right as people we like the game gets
played right so like sure she knows that
like he's kind of full of crap but she's
also going along with it because she
wants to believe that it's true right
she doesn't want to believe this guy
could potentially be bruce wayne it may
also be she just genuinely believes him
and so he actually ends up telling
leslie tompkins that one of the things
that he's not necessarily proud of is
the fact that he is essentially
manipulating her but what he says is the
mission is all that really matters and
it's all that ever mattered at the end
of the day she's just a means to an end
and so one of the things he realizes is
that by going through this and and
basically downloading all of her case
files that there are striking
similarities among those people who were
killed by the imposter batman that he
hadn't picked up on right some of these
are that two of the imposter's victims
were cellmates eight out of the 11
victims overlapped their sentences at
blackgate prison the victims were all
killed in a three-mile radius which as
batman describes it is enormous in terms
of gotham's density unless you have
access to a surveillance network and he
says but there was one more staggering
pattern nine out of the 11 imposter
victims were sentenced by the same judge
a guy named alex mccart and so of course
batman ends up tracing down alex mccard
because while he wouldn't go as far as
to say that like he thinks that this
judge right is the guy who's dressed up
as batman beating people up because he
doesn't fit the mo he's an older guy he
doesn't have the strength to overpower
people who are 20 years younger than him
and twice his size right he just doesn't
quite have the ability to do that but
you know batman comes to this from the
perspective that like he might know
something about it and so what we end up
learning here we kind of get a little
more information involving like gordon
and all those different guys and one of
the things that we learn is that because
of the fact that that jim gordon and
batman were working together and batman
was basically a vigilante who in turn
was snatching up criminals and then
handing them over to the gotham city
police department that essentially the
city had ruled or at least a had ruled
that their civil rights were violated by
batman and so what it meant is that none
of the rulings that were that were
handed down by alex mchard could stand
on top of that what they ended up
discovering is that five judges were
basically on the payroll from the three
crime families in gotham city so what it
meant is that between these crooked
judges along with batman violating
people's civil rights that essentially
all these different cases were just
overturned just all these criminals that
have been busted were all released back
out there again and that jim gordon
himself his career was destroyed he was
out right like literally ran out of
gotham city and that's why we don't see
him here because he's basically gone
right he's out of the picture now beyond
that once bruce is able to essentially
start using the information gained from
wesker surveillance and wong is able to
do the same thing what they do is they
realize a couple different things one
wong realizes that basically batman has
been using the sewer systems to travel
around gotham city we already knew that
but what batman realizes is the
imposter's doing the exact same thing
and in fact he's actually using sewer
systems that no one's supposed to know
about now if you guys remember the last
video that we did the only person that
seemingly has that kind of information
is otis right the rat catcher and so
what batman realizes is that otis has
seemingly been helping the imposter
batman now here's the thing we'll talk
about this here in a second because
there's a little more going on than it
seems but of course where batman
basically races off to catch otis
ultimately the cops get there before he
does and because the police suspect him
as either the imposter batman or at
least as far as they're concerned batman
who's basically killing people or they
believe he has some kind of information
they of course end up arresting him and
basically taking him away and so at that
point what you get is this crazy
situation which is really just a page
out of the dark knight when wong is like
keep your eyes out for batman because if
this guy has information that batman
uses this guy could be the way that we
catch him and so batman as a guy who
kills is gonna be looking to either kill
this guy or the very least get him out
of our custody and so that's where
things are nuts is because literally
batman just sends this wrecking ball
down onto like the police cars and just
smashes pretty much all of them and so
where wong is able to like get out of
the rubble right able to like finally
find batman where he's basically there
trying to free otis batman essentially
knocks the gun out of her hand and then
kicks her right sides are flying and
this is kind of a big deal here because
at that point he basically grabs otis
and then he starts interrogating him
right like smashing his head in water
different things like that like who's
the imposter batman and so on but otis
doesn't understand and it's actually
really really sad otis doesn't
understand because in his mind batman
was the guy who saved his life he's the
guy who saved him from people who were
going to try to kill him and so in his
mind him and batman were basically
friends right like they were great
friends like batman was the guy that
saved him now the reality here is that
they're not friends and they were never
friends but otis sees them as the two of
them being friends because it's really
just an act of desperation right you
know batman's the only person that
really paid any attention to otis and so
because of that he's like we're friends
now right that's not true and again
that's where things get crazy because
we're gonna end up finding out that like
the whole situation with otis and batman
is a lot more interesting and a lot more
wrapped up than it initially appears to
be but beyond that what ends up
happening here is that blair wong is
just kind of like enough is enough right
like at this point batman has literally
attacked us right just a face like a
front on attack it was different when he
was like killing what were basically
criminals and when we wouldn't
necessarily turn a blind eye to it he
wasn't really attacking us head-on so we
would just kind of investigate this the
way cops investigated but once batman
attacked the cops and it was done with
people being able to record it the cops
looked totally inept now they have to
save face and that's where wang
basically goes to the evidence lockup
and ends up picking the lock grabbing a
gun that effectively belongs to other
people and then in turn when her partner
hatcher shows up she's like what in the
world are you doing like you're not
supposed to be here you know and she's
like i'm getting ready to go to war like
uh do you want to join me and it's
actually i mean this is really what
they're gonna do it's not the worst move
ever use guns from evidence lockup
because it just wouldn't be traced back
to them right as long as they keep their
fingerprints off of it it's not like
it's a department issue firearm that
they're using the serial numbers cannot
be traced back to them as the actual
owner so basically they could just pull
off some crazy stunt and nobody would be
any the wiser to the fact that it was
actually them but with that being said
guys we're gonna bring this to an end
again i love this i can't wait to record
or at least release the final part of
this because the final part is just
absolutely amazing but let me know you
guys think down in the comments section
thank you all for watching and i will
catch you all later
peace